actually you this is the last time I met
a stranger yeah before that that guy
over there it was playing William
Shakespeare before that you know I think
today has been just a day of meeting
strangers so it's I mean I love meeting
new people and making new connections so
[Music]
I'm so down I love women
what if I get nervous and don't know
what to say hey Jeannie Christina
Christina immaculate I'm Amanda
I'm Cheryl I'm Jennifer I'm Scarlett I'm
Ashley Ashley Amy nice to meet you hi
I'm Ashley Presley Sarris nervous as I
am
absolutely I'm sweating did she also
grab you from the street what made you
decide to come over and help with her
project because I was an art major
myself and I have been in similar shoes
here in Balboa Park having to do a
performance art thing that I really
didn't want to do I totally can okay
well that's really easy because that's
the easy thing to compliment you want to
like have empathy and like help someone
out who has been a position that you
know that's a great compliment yeah
thank you you're welcome
so you also were randomly stopped with
yeah I don't know I just wanted to
support someone who was doing something
that seems hard till I get rejected a
lot I'm sure a lot of people walking on
by and say like no thank you
because that was my first big thing also
so that's a common theme now if I select
push into your fear exactly yeah well
that is admirable as well you're here
and it's also nice just to know other
people helping other people and I can
tell that you're a really good person
thank you you too really nice to meet
you too Leslie awesome I've never
stopped and actually talk to a stranger
yeah this is a great opportunity it is
volcanion Wow I was any trying to go to
Canada really yes that's nice just don't
go in the winter unless you're skiing
it's freezing I'm never gonna steam
before it really no I love your ponytail
thank you
your box bathes your whole like style
for sure would you get it um thrifting I
was gonna guess that it was stuck there
yeah I love tonight did you your own
bike question yes I just did this
actually it kind of looks a little jank
from the back though I would have been
like all chunky in the tried to get the
snake it's like you're but because
they're lazy well I think that you seem
like a very genuine person and someone
that's very kind
you know that I would appreciate having
you as a friend and I like your energy
you like a lot of bounce to you can I
ask what's your zodiac sign was out jim
and i Gemini on my best friend's a
gentleman I am a Libra a Libra oh my god
yet a lot I like your smile hey have a
straight smile really yeah I always
think my smiles like a Jane David like I
got braces and I still feel like they're
not straight yesterday I don't like my
teeth thank you I mean don't say that I
don't like them they're small no my
smiles no you're fine you're perfect
thank you
I mean it like I think too many women
are really credible than the way
everyone's like everyone looks at the
media and it's like I should look like
that out and then girls start thinking
like should I give lip injections and
it's like just you know don't do it
everyone everyone's beautiful in their
own way
yeah my biggest struggle right now I
think staying focused you know I feel
like I can't continue to distract myself
with little things yesterday in regards
to like my own goals sake hey these are
my goals but I get distracted with Oh
hanging out with friends or like oh I
have to do this instead I have to do
that and also taking care of myself
how about you I think for me it's
also kind of like concentrating I go to
work for five days a week and I go to
school four days a week so I tend to
push everything away that's
understandable though you do a lot so
how many days after you get to just
Wednesday oh that's not enough
I know let's be exhausted oh yeah but
it's okay it's a sacrifice you have to
make you're getting money in education
exactly yeah when you'll be done you'd
be like eh it was worth it what's your
major
I'm going for to be a surgical
technician okay
I thought the ones where they cut people
and stuff kinda squeamish do you want to
be anything else um I think for me it's
figuring out what that is going to be I
love modeling but I also just love
nature in people so I would consider
maybe becoming a counselor
yeah but that's a lot of schooling do
see yourself doing it I do I do see
myself done over here I'm 24
yeah a lot of time yeah but that's a lot
of times that I'm gonna give up I mean
sacrifices yeah indeed this is a great
conversation
I don't know it's been a minute we do
years I think from school I made a lot
of people okay but we doesn't go to be
friends because we're in the CVS thank
you for being so intellectual
oh man I'm understanding it open I like
how open you are you seem so like
natural oh thank you you too it was very
easy to do yeah it's not awkward at all
like with you it just feels like normal
it flowed yeah I'm glad thank you do you
live in America no I live in Mexico
all right I live in England and Lucy
listen New Zealand so you come a long
way how is I think this is cold at the
moment very good cold and wet a lot like
your necklaces is really pretty
what are those stones turquoise yeah
they're really lovely what major do you
want to be when you grow up I want to be
a photographer
really yeah or a designer I I'm very shy
when I'm talking English but when I talk
in Spanish it's like all I come up yeah
I see
oh no I get it cuz I'm an immigrant tale
from Russia
so speaking in English at times are
really hard for me but it's how you can
think and yeah but when you are talking
is like I have to thank everything you
have to think about each word the way
you translate it it's very good it is
definitely but you're doing a really
good job when I first moved here it was
so hard to find people to talk to
because I could not say certain words
and it's they could understand what I
was trying to say but I was your age
when I first moved here and I think
you're doing so much better than me when
I first moved here I could only say hi
how are you and after that it's like mom
what is this thing to me but you're
doing really great
my my brother is amazed translator so
you're not using him right now so you're
doing pretty
the people here are so nice like you
you're a good person - thank you and I
like your talking oh thank you
I like your rings alike oh I like your
ribbing you thank you
I really like your smile yeah I like
your hair the cut I really like your
outfit it looks very like young but also
hit pretty cool and you were very open
so I really liked that - you look like
an independent moment okay thank you
appreciate it
I love your outfit oh thank you so much
I love the headband and the glasses come
well thank you I wouldn't watch summer
Walker last night and you're giving me
the vibe oh thank you of course you have
beautiful hair oh thank you actually
just admire ours - I really like how
just like it clothes blends in really
well how are you Simon you good
Andy what's your name Sarah nice to meet
you beautiful style
thank you so where are you from I'm from
friends Sam yeah no our friends and I'm
traveling in USA so it's my first time
here really and I'm so exciting it's
beautiful I eat a lot of burgers okay
right yeah I think I will come back to
friends with ten more kilos
I know you you want to try to write did
you graduate yeah okay you know Vanessa
yeah right yeah okay yeah she's my best
friend yeah are you in her class no oh
no I'm a stranger
oh yeah apparently yeah well okay you're
a familiar face because I went to the
same high school as you but I don't even
know your name but I just know that we
you guys gonna come here together no
this is why did you move here
we had a baby my husband and I
congratulations we lived in San
Francisco and we were tired of the city
life with the kid yeah I mean this is a
city but not as bad as something like oh
yeah well it seems like you must be a
great mom if you uprooted your whole
life just to move here to have a better
life for your kid thank you know this is
very warm I think you're very warm too
thank you you have a beautiful smile
thank you very pretty eyes thank you you
too my favorite thing about my mom I
love how you're so right and how you're
always they give up others before
yourself and you yeah
I'm how she is cheery thoughtful she
does consider other people's feelings
and and very smart
and loving and very bashful a very
modest high just want to tell you I love
your necklace oh thank you so much yeah
you love about it I love is that Jesus
week oh definitely I love that oh yeah
are you religious oh definitely you
believe in God so much more than ever
and that's why God keeps me going and
helps me meet beautiful and wonderful
people like you thank you when's your
birthday
this Sunday oh my god shall be birthday
thank you this little one might be a say
a Scorpio just like you she is also
gonna be a beautiful strong woman oh wow
and she's definitely gonna love being
herself because she comes from amazing
people like you thank you very much
welcome same to you
what is your name my name is Bernadette
Alisha nice to meet you Alicia
I hope you have a wonderful day Thank
You same to you and may God bless you
thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone before you go I've been
getting a lot of comments about how some
of you aren't being notified every time
I upload a new episode so I thought I'd
let you know that the only way you'll be
notified every time I upload is if you
also have to notification bail after you
subscribe the subscribe button means
that you're subscribed to my channel
thank you and the notification bell
means that you'll know every time I put
up a new episode other than that I
thought it would be fun to make a little
comparison video of women complimenting
women versus men complimenting men
that's on my Instagram so if you want to
check it out follow me on there at
Thoreau why eh that's it thank you guys
for everything and I'll see you soon
[Music]